Yeah, so that's a huge slot...
...and it's one of the most famous shows in America. And it certainly,...
...I think, the longest running perhaps or the least out there.
Probably. I mean, actually, we've got a piece coming up...
...in a few weeks time about a show called Guiding Light,...
...which I've never even heard of.
The Hirudora. Yeah!
And that's been running since the days of radio. 72 years.
Although, it's about to get axed...
...or in fact, I think,...
...it already has finished at the end of September or something in America.
Really?
Because the sponsors finally pulled out, because of dropping ratings.
Oh! The lights going out?
Yup.
Wow! So, what are they gonna do for the Michishirube? That's gonna be tough.
What are they gonna be guided by?
You know, that's a huge show.
I remember people watch that, you know, I mean, religiously.
At least, they used to.
Evidently, not anymore.
Yeah! Guess what? As The World Turns...
...and General Hospital, these are the big afternoon soap operas.
And they run every day, right?
Yes! Yeah and you know, the plots are bizarre.
You have to read like... If you don't watch for a couple of days,...
...you have to read like a manual to figure out what's going on.
'Cause, you know, it's like, you know, Bob's girlfriend,...
...Samantha is actually the daughter of Bob's wife, Martha.
But they didn't know, because Martha's twin sister was actually flirting with Bob...
...and then, she switched places with Martha before, you know,...
...before she got abducted by the alien in a coma.
You know, it's really intricate stuff...
...but people follow it religiously like I said, so they know what's going on.
And I, you know, I turned on to watch for like 10 minutes and I can't... never mind.